when I first saw the original Little
Mermaid my whole world changed
like so many of us little girls we all
just wanted to be mermaids
I think the little mermaid is an iconic
powerful story it was important to
expand and make it a fuller experience
this little mermaid reflects what it
means to want something greater for
yourself
voice
[Music]
so emotional she set the bar and no one
ever surpassed it
I've been watching you for a long time
now too Melissa McCarthy as Ursula she's
extraordinary she's so dishy and
conniving we got a deal I'm gonna just
give you the premium package kid she's
hilarious and terrifying true
true is
Little Mermaid it was the first film I
ever scored it's especially emotional
coming back and with lin-manuel Miranda
who was so brilliant the songs we've
written expand what little mermaid is I
feel really proud to work on The Little
Mermaid because these characters live in
my heart
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
the world that Rob Marshall created
precious boundaries he's doing something
special
just a dream come true
[Music]